what's happening
near the brand error area if you're in
the United States area Brea California
is where Bryan Callen will be December
I'm sorry October 24 25 26 at the brain
brain improv the new Bray improv God
don't do that with your face now that
was a rougher area around December 19th
goddamnit
Oh on October 27th that's a Sunday Kalyn
and friends at the county store for a
charity I take it the veil burger they
will be but they're not yet pretty soon
this is a great read yeah mine you're
actually available October 17th to 19th
that's next week I'm in Philly
Philadelphia helium Thursday Friday
Saturday then I'm at the ice house
shopping friends October 24th and then
November Dallas Salt Lake City get your
tickets Kansas City just hit the streets
and the big one at Lenox it E New Jersey
guy casino out there
I think there's UFC fights at night
we're doing something fun with that
Atlantic City casino take is at T fat K
calm but Philly OC the next Thursday
Friday Saturday diva calm look when you
are on the keto diet which might be the
best way to lose weight I know you swear
by it and there you do it you don't know
if you're necessary are in ketosis
well guess well get tricky take the
guessing out bro take the guesswork out
yeah and I keep keto they have a keto
breathalyzer yes breathe into it and it
tells ya it's an app keto breath sensor
and Premium Subscription it's available
get ki TOCOM slash fighter the keto app
is available for your Android for your
iPhone all you got to do search Quito in
your App Store that's key toe KEYT oh
and the Quito breath sensor Quito
Premium Subscription are available at
get Quito dot-com slash fighter
so the Quito app is available again both
on Android and iOS on your iPhone but
this why it's important Quito breath
sensor is the most accurate
easiest way to measure level ketosis and
get real-time personalized feedback on
your diet via the app Quito will help
you lose weight improve your health and
feel better
the app also will let you know
straightforward food
recipes resources from your favorite
restaurants there's no more guessing
there's a so many people always asking
about questions on Kido this is it
that's what you need all you gotta do is
go to get key TOCOM slash spider $8 a
month that's all it is it's $8 a month
you can up rent a keto premium for
access to videos articles recipes
restaurant guys priority support member
teams and additional resources go to get
keto dot-coms last fighter enter promo
code fighter for 2004 first purchase
there's a performance tool that has
changed the way people track their
fitness and optimizes their training ok
it's worn on your wrist it's a heartrate
monitor the pairs to the app that
provides daily personalized analytics
and insights on recovery on strain and
ready for this on sleep you guys tell me
what it is
the most precise measurements you can
get our boys if you're doing some sort
of sober October our boys Bert Kreischer
Ari Shaffir rogue in Tom Segura their
rock in the whoop to decide who's doing
best who's getting the rest they're
using that's how good whoop is WH oh you
know me I've been swearing by whooping
for quite some time my hikes calculates
how many calories I burn how far I went
when I'm on my peloton peloton tells me
something but I know two ft exactly how
many calories I'm burning now put the
rest at night if I'm getting good sleep
a sleep when I'm on the road it lets me
know it's the most precise thing you can
do to measure recovery your strain your
sleep alright your mind your heart rate
through sleep totally asleep quality
measure your heart rate where you're
working out whatever you're doing it is
on the money take the guessing out of it
a five-day battery life you can recharge
it so dang easy just leave it on your
wrist and right now you get the new woop
3.0 loop has given you guys $30 off your
purchased with the code fighter just go
to woop calm that's wh oo p calm use the
code fighter at checkout and save $30 to
optimize the way you train the way you
rest the way you sleep and you guys get
started now Boop calm sober October is
here
did a couple things that are already you
got a min ha bro I'm hot here's I want
to go with the first one we're going to
skip over very quickly it's Monday
okay I want to do a podcast I get back
Monday I it's what [ __ ] rock it is it's
[ __ ] rock Monday we always talk about
[ __ ] rock Monday we're [ __ ] we're rockin
with our [ __ ] racket on Monday we're
jacking on Mondays now I'm all pumped
I'm ready to go I get a text from my
brother over here Brenda job I'm here
and ready when you are you wrinkly [ __ ]
so so we're starting off already I had a
couple drinks last night did some
stand-up had a cup of pop yeah yeah so
when daddy wakes up at 52 ain't so easy
don't have the enzymes still a little
cloudy
you understand so what kind of drinks
did you have they had some whiskey had
some plans come on Bubba that that's my
[ __ ] can reduce you to blend the Mambo
you send me a PM you didn't Bryan Cooley
my buddy introduced me to plants but
wait did you notice me I did of course
oh yes learn the life you've learned so
come on now I got you in a stand up
right what's that I brought you
understand I'm ahead
wait Oh wipe it blur I was in I was in I
was in [ __ ] Nashville Tennessee my
boy Brian Cooley a black belt teacher in
has a school in Nashville okay sheets
and he was drinking this really great
bourbon I go what is is he that's a plan
in there nice he he knows his he knows
but you show me a video of you and frank
grillo and uh who happy i was drinking
some Pappy Hwee yo your dream pad with
our boy from so frank grillo his son
Remy and myself I go to say hi at scopa
Paulo Pablo Pablo who's the owner you
know Pablo yeah yes he sits down with us
start talking about Pappy he brings us
some pappy he brings Frank a tequila
that it's the oldest maker in the world
and of course it's ridiculously
expensive to smooth tequila but did you
drink Pappy's
attracts would you think's a 15 year
about 15 um if you if you put a brands
next to the Pappy's blinds all day you
know what I mean that's what I'm saying
you know what I mean it's oh no I
haven't had the 25 year the 20 year me
neither but again that's because Pappy's
is restricted absolutely you know this
it's like it's like an Opus one if you
drink up it's one because it was so
popular back then the name is what
you're paying it's changed to like the
exclusive shoes are they the
best-looking probably not there's
better-looking shoes
correct but they're so limited everybody
wants yeah so they don't do that with
your hands keep your hands down today
with your hands down today came in hot
well because girls don't call me back
don't call me if you're gonna fight with
a bum now hold on okay I got a lot to
lose I know that dude but I had a temper
and bumped hey leave me thumbs are gonna
bum they're gonna bump bums are gonna
bug bought the bum KP on guy using older
than me young bum a young bum taller
than me young young dumb let's go let's
use the proper let's not be offensive
with bomblets karma hobo a young ho
hobos betters hobo worse hope or bum
either way what's the correct gentleman
who has a gentleman who has a major
problem with alcohol and hasn't gotten
his life together at 38 435 it's a
problem young you're taller than me
younger there's a woman who can't catch
her breath and she's on the phone right
outside and I go III because I'm good
samaritan save-a-ho
and yeah i didn't say but home home and
that didn't say well some even call me
bit of a hero
maybe the skinny hero heard that that's
in the media not opt-ins neighbor drunk
also yeah keep your nose out other
people's business there's a lady there's
a lady in in distress okay so daddy's
instincts we should buy a protect not
sure was the show is it everybody 610 i
keep on keepin on god I'll pull over fix
your tire of course but I come running
up I go you okay honey and she's got her
bags on the ground I immediately said
something's wrong
really bags are on the ground she was
crying he's crying but she's not crying
huh and she goes I'm an alcoholic I
drank and my son kicked me out okay a
lot of info just my son comes down he's
a guy in a tie a nice guy sorry guys
backpack came home from work obviously
goes you're not gonna be around a child
drinking I told you I'd fly you down
here if you drink I'll kick you out the
stuff thank you so he's at that point
with her you have to get out no it can't
be around the kids mom the hobo so Derek
she's going to go yeah I told you yeah
hope o / bum / person with a problem I
don't know about Susan is there correct
or transient right transient no come on
hey we gotta quit with these pros okay
how's that with this one of God's
children who just has a flagon with
alcohol is that better want to know I'm
sure that doesn't work a fallen angel a
fallen angel with bloodshot eyes eyes at
six foot two and a whole lot of Hmong in
the mouth of a misfit a homeless misfit
with a lot among in the mouth Hmong now
we live like a white paste it's a it's a
low chair see when a camel choose
wouldn't want a camel or cows blood
yeah as cud really builds up he's got
cud
yeah really builds up he's a cub mouth
cool we cool he's a cud mouth and he
goes hey what are you draw that woman
get away from her and he comes over with
a huge bottle of Jack with a neck that's
this thick is my wrist okay
the neck of the bottle yeah like might
like to think of my [ __ ] oh when it's
fully on hot okay okay
not getting your hand around it though
right so so he comes over he's Captain
save-a-ho - yeah and I see that he's
walking towards I'm like he's gonna hit
the guy with the bottle and I allow I go
hey I go alright cuz he walks by me go
stay the [ __ ] out of this you know he
turns on me now he turns on me homeless
again homeless now they put their nose
in everything yep he turns they have
nothing to do so they're looking for
some sort of entertainment you're right
now now I don't know if you know this
the other day I was on stage I was
moving woman said do you train or
something in martial arts and and what
did I say Brennan asked me be the woman
oh my god do you train I am our life now
that makes me upset and I don't now ask
me what I my god in what and pretty much
everything okay well it's very general I
don't believe you I know but you should
have said UFC I know but just as UFC to
get your [ __ ] side ha
I trained a nutrient UFC train there's
nothing works UFC oh wow form about in
UFC so I trained you I trained in UFC
people say all the time what are you
trained UFC that's well that's like
saying what he trained NFL well that's
not a sport is it did I give you my
coffee
where's my hope that was my god I gave
that to you right not here and you
poured it in it yeah no you just took my
cross like the bum I thought you gave it
to me to sip on
now it's good I got my own coffee Oh cuz
what happened I take I don't mind I got
you this I knew you wanted this funnel
mill this is from funnel but when your
coffees at I just thought I thought I
mistook a bet I'd be sure yeah well now
cuz you're like cuz that's better cuz
that's funnel mill admit that final
mills better than any coffee there call
brew it's it's nice they're cold Brews
nice yeah so I'm better black rifle but
it's nice I understand I understand but
I'm saying in the knee I understand and
you're right and you're right solutely
right so you so bums are gonna bump the
bump bump start for you to have no
business being there right they're gonna
fight each other right
bum bum starts moving towards lumps
bodied up though yeah bones body up I'm
jealous of the bums when the shredding
right they don't need much
yeah so jealous now if you're a study of
the human form and you were if you were
if you are a student of the human form
of you a student of moved movement yeah
if you were Ito portal of you'd say yeah
whatever Conor McGregor's well then you
know you were fired but yeah okay
whatever he would he would go oh I
noticed that you put your weight on your
back foot
that was impressive did you ready to go
I'm like you're loading up my heel came
up we call it the rattlesnake yeah
you're cocky guy swings the bottle I
[ __ ] see you slap before I come back
bang I bring a hug him a two-piece Boop
he goes like that I go Babu opera head
he pulls a knife a sort of machete of
the large nut is that my jet this was
right outside here this was outside
weird you called me and I looked out
there I just saw an older black man and
you stalking and I saw this is a white
he's a white this out they were both
both people were whiteness that to be
meant they're both Caucasian okay woman
was Caucasian and the the nun was
Caucasian the sums [ __ ] is the bum the
hobo one of God's fallen angels was
Caucasian oh well he pulls to my check I
I was like and I go I go hell up in here
now you're hurt
feelings I said oh wow yeah I go now
you're hurt my feelings in here too you
nasty and I and I and I have a tough
time believing they slew him he's dead
he's out front
oh wow but he's not out front because I
cut this is gross
so anyway turd if anybody was listening
she nighter I chopped him anything this
transfer please skip ahead duly noted
give it I chopped him up and I pushed
him into the storm drain so dude he's
now with Pennywise thank God you made it
dude thank it banned barely yeah so the
early bro maybe the part within my chat
there and the fighting is maybe at least
above recognize from Joker I was hoping
it was like oh my god you're the Joker
and you thought he's being hostile and
killed him I got somebody be like dude
loved your camión the Joker then I had
good friends going I thought I heard
your voice bro you were blurry in the
background but I heard your voice I was
like that's bets a little better yeah
movies killing it though I am killing it
here look really really good yeah man no
one saw it in here I'm waiting till next
weekend there were a lot of weird
threats go shooting like that's fair
it's fair I'm gonna go that's it oh I'm
definitely I'm gonna try going this week
for your babysitter oh yeah trying you
know this week definitely want to see it
the critics were mixed but the people
it's a holler I know there's such
themselves like they're such fools yeah
get out of here yeah I was doing press
in Pittsburgh and I was on the thing is
your boy still he used to open up for
you Oh Ben I mean I'm bill bill Crawford
yeah he's great he's great they're great
great big station and they're great he
was flood man good times together Mac
good guy yeah but they're like the main
voice of the Pittsburgh Steelers at an
NFL expert he's the play-by-play college
Steelers Wow and they had another guy
who he's there but he does like movie
reviews you know Todd failed me my best
friends our good friend these days in
Fatah to him Todd Phillips started
together I know Todd Phillips you know
Todd Phillips yeah this dude comes on
the station [ __ ] on the Joker hey
man oh man not this are you talking
about are you talking about are you
doing oh yeah what are you doing dude so
easy my friends right what are you doing
it's so easy to be to hate on Todd
Phillips just shouldn't be making dramas
I'll tell you that much it should have
stick to comedy
okay drag but everybody disagrees with
you sir can't everybody disagrees with
you huh huh it's the biggest opening
weekend ever in October
huh so what should he stick to but then
what can finish gonna win the Oscar so
what were you saying I write some people
say it's the greatest movie of all time
superhero Wyatt and I win which movie do
you like you is Black Panther the [ __ ]
out is that what he said yep
all right it's disappointing I went oh
oh okay we can't have this conversation
I can't have this conversation sometimes
you joined the hype beats back Panther
was good for reasons sometimes you get
to a point what I do is I got like a lot
of the women in out in Los Angeles when
you speak to a lot of the cute gals in
Los Angeles okay
what I like to do is I like to
substitute their face for a guy's face
sock them and then well I just and then
I go what if a guy was talking this way
oh I really just you gotta get out of
here immediately before I I had break
lipoamide allergic reaction yeah yes and
it's like you've been getting away with
this terrible conversation because of
the only said that I say what also I'm
seeing what I hate I I don't want
anybody's opinion on [ __ ] before cuz it
experience because if someone goes oh
it's the greatest movie I've ever seen
you not gon like there we go greatest
move all-time and then no matter what
it's like a little patent it's like one
splat once upon a time in Hollywood I've
been waiting for years for that moody
cow
I am balls deep in that old-school
Hollywood late 60s that's my [ __ ]
Quinton T no that's my shot and I was
like I mean I've never been so excited
for a movie
so then I didn't live up to the height
but then I saw the second time when I
knew what to expect
love it yeah but even more so Joker I
don't want to hear [ __ ] matter of fact I
like that the critics are hating on it
it does it does even more justice yes it
does because you know it's killing how
about Martin Scorsese they go what do
you think of the Marvel movies he does
it's just not my thing it's not like to
me it's not like you know it's not it's
not real yeah he likes to tell stories
the irishman I can't wait to see I can't
wait season we see a preview of the
Irishman's that Posse and can't show you
I heard it I heard it's really really
good once it out is it's out soon I
heard it's really good you know my only
problem with it it's Netflix you know my
only problem with it what look at the
ages of these dudes they're all how
Pacino's he'd be fine yeah they're all
dude it's interesting they've been doing
it forever
I remember 27th on Netflix November 27th
mmm Joe Pesci that should be good
Martin Scorsese doesn't miss EMS he's
just well I almost [ __ ] that Robert to
know he does miss he's movies I think
just for the money yeah uterus even get
arguing with his girlfriend there we go
let's all have to make these [ __ ] movies
oh yeah I mean I I've heard I've heard
he only likes dark meat no no I've heard
him you know and my friend played a
message that he played to him when he
didn't use him in a movie now you'll
never hear it but it was I was I ha ha
oh he is big boy [ __ ] he's a sore loser
it's Robert in there yes apparently he
drinks a little bit and gets kind of
nuts
sounds like he's awesome oh yeah I mean
he's Robert De Niro's Robert De Niro I
love him but yeah him Joe Pesci is cool
I love him he loved your pets yeah big
time you know you know bet she became
what he is great story what Raging Bull
my favorite movie of all time won an
Oscar well put De Niro won an Oscar De
Niro in Raging Bull it's an iconic movie
because De Niro put on weight for the 67
pounds no actor had ever done anything
like that no actor I'd ever come close
to that
the Christian Bale's and all these guys
lose not be the first guy to do it yeah
on such a level not only was De Niro but
he also started boxing like was was
boxing like taking it really seriously
he trained with Jake LaMotta you know
he's the other guy people are like he
was the first guy people said you know
some box was like you know he could fake
it he became an amateur fighter he could
have he was he was getting in there and
fighting and ah blah blah blah so again
this is this way he was the first guy to
do this stuff and so Joe Pesci who was
incredible in it had been an actor quit
he quit acting and was doing he was
working in a restaurant in Brooklyn an
Italian restaurant waiter and De Niro
saw him in some obscure film some
whatever is food that guy be great for
my brother let's get him in Raging Bull
and they couldn't get in touch with them
in Raging Bull yeah oh well so he this
is a Scorsese movie calls the restaurant
because it's Robert De Niro and Frank
Joe Pesci gets tough [ __ ] out here and
hung up on him
calls back goes hey listen to me this is
Robert De Niro I saw you in the movie I
think you'd be great in this movie and
so does Marty so this guy so been an
actor who quit Wow so waiter Wow
Brooklyn and goes all right boom and
then with that of course wins an Oscar
they go Goodfellas they go way back way
back so Martin Scorsese and De Niro
they're super close oh my god well they
they go back to mean streets if if you
if I may if I may if I may I want you to
watch Robert De Niro audition and not
get it for he auditioned for James
Caan's role in The Godfather
oh wow in The Godfather when Al Pacino
says I'm gonna go avenge my father and
son is like you're a civilian you get
his brains are on this guy there is
that's a young you get his brain so
they'll be nice and yv leaked sued
Michael that's what happens spectacular
but it was funny really like Pilar's his
long hair like is it burning sighs Brian
didn't do it all right you proved it to
me you can do it guys
see he's improvising there hmm did you
get the part Wow
they didn't get the part there there are
a lot of those about the Godfather a lot
of actors who you see auditioning and
they're just actors in New York and they
became legends yeah yeah and you see how
this hair is long I was used to wear his
hair really long and he had it pinned on
little stuff yeah bro and you're a young
man you see that you're like look at the
hat he wears now that's a New York
[ __ ] at this new whoa now he owns
that Hotel the Greenwich right uh yeah
the Creta so tell us my favorite hotel
yeah it's the best and Locanda Verde
which is the green veranda which is the
restaurant right next to it he owns that
too that is phenomenal Neel no because
he does sir he also owns a lot of real
estate in New York yeah he's real
anxious and then also he oh he said he
was one of the main guys developed
Ryback correct and he brought Nobu you
know we brought Nobu to America and
brought it to California at is correct
he's hell of a businessman but I back
then there was nobody working on that
level that Daniel day-lewis and
Christian Bale that's who they that's
who they look at so interesting and he
his hero is Robert Duvall and if you
watch Robin Tomic right of course and
you've all right why everybody anybody
if you have a hero please know they had
a hero it's how human when everyone has
their North Star right what has his
North Star and then you're gonna develop
your set off of it you'd he steals em
and and Pacino and those guys and all
those young guys used to go and watch
the ball he'd do it when he wasn't doing
theater they were like [ __ ] the og
Duvall okay if you watched an era when
he's younger he's copying Duvall when he
did the Great Santini and Apocalypse Now
he's he'd laugh like this that's where
yeah that's where he got oh and he
copied his laugh it's just what human
beings do yeah dinero de niro then
Raging Bull awakenings whoo man I mean I
couldn't get enough of it III reposted
retweeted this thing because he was on
CNN and then went you know Fox News said
this he goes [ __ ] he looks around and
get he knows he's live you not supposed
to you look trans there what do you
think it is
[ __ ] them that's what I think about that
and I put Monday vibes just how he
doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah but people
thought I was retweeted cuz of Trump
stuff I'm like no no I just like how he
doesn't give a [ __ ] it's Robert De Niro
isn't he
Fox News CNN his father was a hell of a
painter his father has paintings in the
Museum of Modern Art I believe or the
Metropolitan I would do is a legit paint
I went to a museum you I went to the
famous Museum the Carnegie Hall or the
Kearney Hall Museum tenaris senior
serious artist killer sweater yell to
the Carnegie Hall Museum
they had Monet's in there not that you
want yeah they had Monet's did cool
stuff look at his dad that's [ __ ]
great but in his dad was you know his
mom's Jewish his dad was an actor too
right I said I was a painter back there
too though maybe a buddy who got to look
at that look at those two
they looked look at me tiger this would
mean tiger that's crazy
yeah De Niro Wow and his mother was
Jewish she was a might have been a poet
I think he comes from his dad's a tell
he comes from an attack I'm a New York
intelligentsia like in New York like you
know art art artistic family boy him is
dead look pretty I first time I've seen
his dad like that I haven't seen that
yeah you love that Museum the Carnegie
Hall Museum yeah they had real Monet's
in there they had Oh Andy Warhol did
this huge Andy Warhol exhibit mmm it was
sick man Wow yeah it was really cool I
love that his words I like Pittsburgh
man Pittsburgh is the lightweight East
Coast couple things about the Pittsburgh
well you should as I'm getting older as
well you should why because there's so
much history Pittsburgh was the Gateway
to the west and Pittsburgh if you look
at the architecture correct me if I'm
wrong the architecture the the again
that that's where Carnegie Mellon is
yeah I mean you got the Carnegie's some
of the richest people in the world at
the time the steel the steel factories
all that even built they build rich is
there but all the buildings everything's
break architectures and Crump's
yeah look at that it looks like it looks
like it let some of them grew up elixirs
like this and you wouldn't think that
about Pittsburgh me and Jay were saying
that like as we get older we appreciate
the arktech in
like just the qualities and like you
don't really see me that out here well I
get so old there and like we stayed at
this hotel called the Auckland er
ridiculous hotel but it's cross street
from the University of Pittsburgh and
the University of Pittsburgh the
buildings were insane it's been there
since like it's one of the oldest
schools in the nation 1818 like nineteen
it said some [ __ ] I mean look I know the
first call it we were there for two
months and I got to know that city and I
was astonished good food oh they love
the Pittsburgh Steelers and all white
well they saw emigrate it's all like
it's all like like people who came from
classes like Serbia Croatia PM that's
where that's where isn't that not um
steep a who's from Ohio steep is from
Ohio there are a lot of guys like that
in Pittsburgh here's what's in store out
Pittsburgh I'm a read off these names
these are guys who born raised in
Pittsburgh played their football in
Pittsburgh you ready for this think of
small Pittsburgh is you ready Dan Marino
Jim Kelly
Joe Namath she's Joe Montana what really
Gannon all the same area all of them Wow
about outliers there's something there
and you're not just talking about oh
these guys went on to play college
football or now Lana you're talking
about holiday like let em be Pella it
was amazing it was an epicenter Dan
Marino clerks they're all like in this
little area like what the [ __ ] well it's
a working class you know the values the
discipline waking up early good people
yeah there's that same with men you know
places like Pittsburgh you know first
first out of the house last one home you
know you just you you meet your kids
like Sebastian Maniscalco talks that
tells that joke about I think my dad met
his former my dad worked all the time
thinking met us formally when we hit
pupa when we were ill is he's like hey
I'm me dad yeah I mean it's true your
dad was the guy Russell newspapers and
and you didn't see maybe the weekends
but then he was golfing yeah the the
food there was I was at college downs
the food was alright we travel outside
of it yeah Club was cool but if that
dude I'm when I say and so the the
Pittsburgh Pirates brought me this
custom Jersey to wear on stage Wow but
it's just like such to me it felt like a
small community but just
[ __ ] everything black and yellow hits
Burt stealers man so when I went on your
boys talk show I made a joke in my kind
of clown Ben Roethlisberger I'm being
thick how thick you then how we're thick
and when we got off here he goes
I would chill I kind of make fun I turn
around all that stuff
he got chill on still in the shade at
the Steeler plant really goes they'd all
this in the show and banner call in or
been a text me like dude what the [ __ ]
why would you let that guy like he
listens to all of is that true I was
like why wait Ben you why would he have
Jews and calm down immediately
why would he do that yeah yeah but as
per ushe laughing why would you even
listen to any of that talk show radio or
any of that [ __ ] man don't take it so
probably doing I get so mad cuz when I
was there they were like don't make fun
of the Steelers whatever you do and I
was during the playoffs and everybody's
wearing the [ __ ] Steelers if not you
know I've never seen anything like you
but it's all they give a [ __ ] about is
this do you know why because there's
such history and people like go back so
many generations there that football was
when everybody would come to that was
their identity yes so the Steelers were
there were Lulu yeah and they're also on
the most winningest programs in the
history of all sports so like they know
winning they're always pretty good it's
what they're known for a Steel City baby
you can get in a fight in Pittsburgh
varies how about how about when you get
to the airport there's two statues once
George Washington once Franco Harris
next to each other so that's we're
getting a nutshell uh you know the
oldest college though is it Carnegie
Mellon no Virginia Virginia back to
check that for me Jim buy pretty sure
Regina's the oldest college in in our
beautiful nation that would make sense
Virginia I think so
University of Virginia Harvard 1650 1636
and John's mother [ __ ] Virginia is not
in the top of our Harvard's the oldest
university in the world yeah it makes
sense it's the best yeah they're the
best is always yeah depends but well
you're some of the great people I mean
if you look at the the people the
founding fathers the people that came in
Mary shoulda known that one st. John's
that's New York oh yeah great basketball
Yale
your Haven Connecticut Pennsylvania Penn
you see a pen
yep okay place looks old
Delaware there you go Jean is not in
there Princeton president I believe
Madison went there so one of the
founding fathers which is named thought
no [ __ ] I hope we get that from
a sauna mod my opener how the [ __ ] would
he know the same for Indian yeah
goddamnit
yeah come on son for heaven's sake
well well Wow piece of Virginia
University or Virginia College Virginia
so could be this is just for knows I'm
talking about one of the first nights
and oldest college no I had no idea
Harvard's the oldest university I didn't
either
I knew is up there but take a look at
their alumni take a look at who came out
of there out of Harvard Oh God and take
a look my Hezbollah captain Reed just
give me the top ten most famous building
kind of bought a Harvard oh yeah I mean
well Mark Zuckerberg I mean but it but
it's like big boys
yeah is a soccer player I think dropped
out of Harvard I yeah to start Facebook
he's even graduate more than they're a
lot of those people to Al Gore Barack
Obama Portman Matt dude Matt Damon
Barack Obama College Online Jones Henry
Kissinger they're Sevilla Ted Kennedy
well there are other people that are
much asked me wait on alone this is
recent let's break the 30 most famous
Harvard students of all time give me
that John Adams John Quincy Adams yeah
got some presidents involved you've gone
be Hayes Teddy Teddy Roosevelt
shut up to his grill yeah Forrester
Franklin D Roosevelt never heard of them
yeah a couple guys I don't know Daly
Marcus I just couple familiar try and
count my fav JFK Sumner Redstone that's
good hold on hold on rut summer go back
to his face he created Viacom okay well
he one of the richest men in the world
crazy crazy diet right now now Sumner
Redstone if you would meet him his
finger
were one on his hand League still
thought they were this and that was on
one hand well what happened they have a
stroke no sir he didn't have a stroke he
there was a fire in his hotel and he
hung from a ledge with one hand for like
a half hour it was it was inhuman it was
impossible to the head and anyone who
knows how Sumner Redstone anyone knows
knows someone Russell wasn't surprised
they were like well that's Sumner
Redstone his his mind was so [ __ ]
strong it was ridiculous there's hand
see his hand look at see that they
always it's just turning well he
destroyed his hand by hanging out a
[ __ ] window Jesus guys yeah and he my
father had a little business deal with
him once not it was worth working for a
bank and called and said Sumner how are
ya cuz my dad trying to be cool and
Sumner Redstone says I said I don't
answer questions like that you know
little professor I'm not here with four
small talking a little [ __ ] small I
don't have time for it let's go well
what are we doing here oh my look at his
[ __ ] hands yeah yeah he was a you see
who else with Darla strong-minded man
very wealthy man yeah terrible picture
of Josh one of the great actors of all
remember your old men one of the
greatest actors of all time
if you see is it when he's young if you
see him in Glengarry Glen Ross oh yeah
oh my god
going chin oh my god sits on sits on the
Supreme Court Court Justice John Lithgow
one of the great actors loved them is an
actor George W Bush all right oh no
George w both didn't go to Harvard might
a yeah I thought do you think you went
to Harvard no nothing for graduate
school did he I think so uh that's a
good interesting I don't remember that
I tell me Jones Wow he's always Al
Gore's roommate in Harvard how about
that really yep I'm surprised Mitt
Romney
65 couldn't look better al gore that
guys are [ __ ] he's soft
well Gore's yeah he's just a softy the
[ __ ] out of here okay he have to take
man classes um I'm not joking arrival
he's got no chin
yeah but I like him Mike Carp Oh is he a
justice Crapo senator Kay keep going I'm
surprised Mike make the list yeah Lloyd
and I find a head of Goldman Sachs mMmmm
but too rich whatever you know I like
the diversity though yeah
least it's all white it's all white boy
[Music]
was he good dropped out though Jennifer
Granholm they mix it up a little bit
some females mr. Barack Obama mm-hmm
[ __ ] tough to get to harvard these
days you know Ashley Judd I'm Ashley
Judd is sexy my age too
how's he a hot second the whole family's
got a cluster if these women get older
man and so what happens is workd rise up
that's what happens with Abbey's only so
many roles for older wait just what
happens men too though unless what do
you mean I work more than I ever have
right yeah 52 well a lot of women you go
through that looks and then it just
stops yeah then yeah it's brilliant
anymore have to write a book about
having threesomes for god sakes yeah
the well dries up yeah it drives up well
for what
yeah she is pretty oh yeah girl family
wealthy surely wanna know one thing of
someone else there no head no but her
old family right they all sing and [ __ ]
I think those guys she does good my god
is that her sister yeah her sister and
her mom they're both the duds yeah
sister Naomi judges water of Naomi Judd
younger Julia well she owned art stuff
no but she does look like that girl a
little bit no that's a girl
yeah now that's a good example of what
an actor thinks that they are bigger
than the business yeah she's [ __ ]
she no sucking [ __ ] about the movie
going I wish I never did that difficult
work rocked up yeah yeah but she was
killing it Holly do I have to use me
Katherine Heigl Heigl Oh she was
crossing Jean Krusty's nothing about us
yeah but but she's very pretty but
you can't you got to be careful because
what happens is the business cuz did you
think you were important or that we
couldn't go on without you I will we'll
see you later though who's actually
judged the family chin for God's sakes
the only one is there a half-sister and
Naomi Judd is your mother
oh yeah oh oh yeah we're known as yep
Dario Franchitti yep yep yep yep yeah
that's right Wynonna Judd and then the
mom yeah the moms pretty too then they
kind of look like the the mice from
Cinderella and when we notice the
thumper yeah or no Gus
you oh you gotta have a thick one in the
family I'm the thick one you know yeah
you you don't have any thick ones in
your family your sister both skinny my
sisters sturdy though yo she's not my
dad sponsorship thick no like well
notice the thick one you know I'm saying
there's always one with a beating
problem she's a big girl
sometimes the haps sometimes people have
just big bones like big heads for each
you know big hips God the mom is
freaking the best looking went well she
sure is easy but she's a cutie pie
though I'm not gonna hurt doctor hey red
head out of the shot but also having a
shot but also yeah would you do this we
get that um a couple things I dyed my
hair purple on Friday
I just thought your hair show dark side
in the sudden it's a lot more purple it
looks pretty cool Thanks and hard to do
I know was it hard here so dark did you
have to diet light first and yeah I had
to bleacher a couple times which sucks
if you wanted to go blonde it would be a
long incest yeah it would be really long
asian here is super stubborn yeah you
ever seen an Asian blonde yeah couple I
feel like Asians who are blondes like
it's a very particular type of person
that will be at this driver yeah and and
I pay hard
the typical whole day at sound like the
best examples I like the contrast
good guy who is is you like her yeah she
is I can see up or not she's we caught
up crimes yeah she calls me daddy you
don't see a ton of just a creep I get
the daggers a little light then bringing
the purple yeah yourself he goes no I
went to my hairstylist her name is Jess
she does uh hair for well she I had to
pay her because the first time I dyed my
hair some girl [ __ ] it up where I had
really long black hair the first time I
got my hair dyed she put bleach on it
you're not supposed to have the bleach
touch
she took my hair and she made the end
point touch higher up and it was so bad
that my hair started to fall out of my
head
god damn yeah hmm so I ended up going to
this girl here named Jess she does here
for like kailani and gez and stuff like
that so she took really good care of me
but yeah it took me a hot minute looks
pretty dope though Thanks
wanna look like a x-men character it
looks cool now you do look like an
excellent character chin what do you do
did you even notice the way trans dress
today Brian like it dude I did not
notice that you got yourself a little
vest on but it's literally a little vest
long black on black crime over here it
looks like a villa on the lawn yes he
does and it shirts a little open I see a
chain chain in there [ __ ] - Lea sent
me justice a picture of his neck he sent
a text message yeah get the [ __ ] out of
the dolly chain choker choker
that's his event that daliyah's is like
a that's his event further would you do
this weekend it got a chain period the
thing could not have been cheap then I
drank coffee and I hung out uh yeah yeah
I don't think he's I don't think he's
posted about huh bummer
uh no tree I can see it no you're not
gonna see all right that's how it's a
thick chain machine here no no no trust
me Jim it's thick I think other people
posted it really but yeah like I saw
Santino and I
saw Whitney post about yeah text my cell
says you know SIA and the Joker you were
so bad why I guess what he looks the fat
girl who's that girl with the tits go up
I'm Albert that girl who's that girl I
don't know I don't know some titties
that though just out in the open with a
tip out
oh great first in Toronto last set it
[ __ ] titty so what'd you do though
Jim I did a few things there's actually
an interesting story - let's hear it I
never had to take this off for Brian's
like there you go just take off
Instagram he has me against a wall there
what the [ __ ] is that you don't think
that no yeah well you know that took the
picture dude well that's weird
oh that was for their pocket his face um
on man
Oh chin I've got a deep tissue massage
so I've never in and downtown LA mmm
it's the first so is the second time I
went I want one time and it was really
painful but I needed it for my back is
killing me right now okay but the second
time I went I they don't tell you who
you yet you just see names so I actually
got a really huge breasted blind woman
she had a the glove you know the black
losses in a cane all that stuff so she's
the one the massage me how was it it was
tough at first but the weirdest thing
and the end of it they had like a hot
towel so I'll have to lay up words right
so my face is facing the sea all yes see
let me finish you up and then she had a
huge huge tip like massive tits yeah and
it she took her
brennick yeah I hope this story don't go
yeah and hit me no no broke up so she
had a towel wrapped it up to where it's
narrow and now hot towel super I did
this happen in between and then she
started pushing up on my neck right all
the way into her tits so my face was in
her tetanus she would do this so my he
said be going like that yeah
it was a weird she's she's been what at
lunch
so the blonde laughs hey
whoa dude he's chin tips number one dude
first of all this is the biggest red
flag of steam for a rub-and-tug this is
I live for these players a franchise
place man bro it dude
fat titties the fake blind lady and she
right now you don't know she's blind
chin right it's grated gimmick you don't
know that hopefully it cost you to close
I was blind I thought it was this
footage jacket yeah I've seen it dude is
up but hold on it was a moist hot towel
or saw Tom Jack burn
oh no dude cuz I always ask you know do
you guys have hot towels here they go
yes I see in there but I'll see you in
the hot towels
dude there's code words I've been here
before I have never been these are words
you use to know something that it's
going down well you just you know the
deal have you been here before I have
favorite place I always wink to just so
they call drugged Matt's her table mats
one rub Matt rub Maps rub Maps days you
are down on this you know this [ __ ] just
the streets dude that's where I get it
educated the streets wow chin so let me
get this straight this blind lady's
rubbing her tits on your head she was
legitimately blind yeah she was doing
this for with her cane good actor did
you request a blind woman because you
know it was weird because she's asking
me where does it hurt and I wanted to
say you know like I wanted a point but I
just clicked out okay left shoulder
blade right shoulder blade neck area and
what are you doing when they go where
does it hurt I go it go and or right
around here uh-huh no your legs you know
my legs are killing me yeah my rod Wow
Tim this is a happy place bro I don't
think so but I mean it was weird my face
was in her tits guaranteed dude and if
it's a boy moist wet towel hot moist hot
yeah what they do not was their music of
course that's what they do
it was with multiple rooms with it what
was the light and give me light it was a
colored lighting she turned off the
lights entirely in our room which was
crazy okay take it easy Brandon what is
the lady sandwich was it I think was
like 70 yes yeah this is Jack please
give me a dress chance I don't let me
investigate no you can't have guys
because you know what Al magical said
that he went to one and she goes she
gives him a massage and she goes do you
want me to make banana cry I don't think
so do you want me to make banana cry oh
man this is most depressing
weepy banana yeah please make banana
cream my bananas sob oh man that's so
disappointing
I mom I've been how are you everyone
cries over [ __ ] tugging rug I don't
you know rub in tights who cares man
no difference get your feet massaged
yeah it's just there's a lot come around
yeah Terry tells it's all hot and moist
and there's just come he's walking out
your iced I have trouble using the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what do you come any with this place or
dislike um yes like in the air I don't
know this is for you
you don't say that this is for you sit
put twice and French I don't know dude
it comes a banana he's getting [ __ ]
sad oh he's crying oh you want me make
the bun and a cry that's what now
magical says God that is not sexy girls
don't have this problem okay like if I
need a real massage everything I go on
thinking here we go yeah what do you
mean girls don't have this problem like
nothing to you you never you're not
worried about if it's legit or not no
one's happy endings for girls really oh
I feel like there probably are places
I'm sure there are but
like that's the thing like guys but like
you know even girl massage if you flip
me over that things ten-hut just the way
it is it's dark I mean mind you getting
massaged dude you're all ten-hut every
time I'll never do a float tank again
cuz people like you that make that yank
it I'm so [ __ ] eyes I don't give a
[ __ ] if it I I was like when you said
that I came out I was like I have to
take six hours now because of course
Brendan's not the only one it's like
kids who pee in the pool they all pee in
the pool all guys with the exception of
Brian come in slow tempo just floating
I'll be fine they go next guy next guy
joy the sea monkeys alibi is a thing now
um but naked I'm in this warm water
bears dangling it's dark dude I get
turned on yeah I don't but all right hey
there you go next guy I'm gonna see a
salt and come come it's pretty salty
anyway from what I hear sanitary though
I don't know though there's filtering
systems I don't get your stick - I don't
care how filthy Oliver's on another one
again it's you man semen and I'm not
into it even though you no offense Jim
you can embed that fan blows right up
your dick hole a pervert huh a little
the whole name is cat women don't have
the same problem you know I feel like
women don't want to have that from a
like random stranger like when I think
of a rub-and-tug
I think of like a random like a dingy
place probably not that sanitary but
because it's jacking off it's not as
unsanitary whereas if it's for a woman
something's entering you yeah like you
have to be a little more particular
about who it is yeah gotta go to a
high-end place exists did you uh let's
switch gears did you put your money on
whitaker or on
stop stop oh no you did you did hmm ooh
my favorite
nothing crazy well what is so damn good
then find enough to an active oh yeah
really
and you saw that you didn't see a
second-round TKO though I mean not I
don't know I I know I called it under
four but I thought I said second round
but kind of member second round two but
I thought I said second round TKO but I
don't know yeah that's doping just
because I just doubt he's that he's that
he's that [ __ ] girl yeah no one's
gonna be him for long is he I'm the same
level kickboxing as someone like Josh
Schilling or those guys oh yeah really
yeah his MMA kickboxing is lightyears
ahead of those guys so he's now gonna
fight Paulo Kosta mhm what's your take
on that who destroy him he'll destroy
how Paul is not technical enough I don't
think try to wrestle on us a little bit
know who did you try not come out I just
don't think he's that's not the best
game to play with I mean he's long range
so good guys problems but stop Ben are
so good man he's acting so [ __ ] good
say he's here for here's here to stay
for a long time yeah besides cost though
there's not a ton maybe dere until if
you were to beat Kelvin you can see that
that'd be good oh you mean because they
have they have similar pedigrees King
looked a be a fun fight yeah yeah how
well he'd have to fight well Mozilla
smaller dere until 570 though where is
he going up to 85 he's going up his next
fight against Kelvin Gastelum
Wow mmm-hmm Daron Shaw has his work cut
out for him
is that a race head I know he's yeah
here's the skills young yeah he's not
that young
but hope I get this [ __ ] together fine
yeah oh dear until Finn oh yeah you pee
so hard on my future don't pee out of
your dick and we'll do some current
events when you get back well do some
current events when you get back you're
gonna pee pee pee pee pee hard pee pee
pee pee pee Oh so one of the reasons
people say bright your hair it's so
thick you're 52
I've never heard that you got a mane
that's never happened it happens all the
time
dude the media says dude
ask me something that's what's going on
have you see how thick this [ __ ] is it's
so thick that's thank you my hair feels
like you're rubbing your fingers through
a musketeer a three musketeers I mean my
track sick bro you you have your hems
customer I'm a hams customer I just put
on my head all the time
next you know I got this rat tail out
the back yeah it's the sides are gone
why I'm saying I look like Brad Pitt yep
I wouldn't say that but I get my my hims
products mailed to me every month I get
my finasteride which is basically what I
take to keep my hair I basically filled
out a questionnaire had the doctor look
at it didn't have to do any doctors
thing and they send me my pills doctor
go Dean take it well well no no no dude
I have gray hair not doing it no no
that's how he did
I don't know sure you take you know my
hair's gotten thicker and I don't care
what you say now if you got a problem
with your dong a lot of guys have
erectile dysfunction for a thousand
reasons and you want to get your you've
the pills that are science and I'm
talking about this these are doctors
this is real science and you want to get
your pills and you don't want to go with
that you know pharmaceutical brand-name
but you want to pay less discreet you
cut out the middleman straight
houses.com no snake oils no no gas
station counter supplements no real
stuff and then prescription solutions
backed by science I'm a customer myself
do it up it's great to it up everybody
yes yeah all right now listeners get
started with hims complete hair kid for
just five dollars right now while
supplies last
it's the only thing keeps your hair it
just is this could cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor of pharmacy somewhere
else go to for hemes dot-com slash
fighter fo r hims dot-com slash fighter
James Caan slash fighter see website for
full details and safety information hey
B let me have some help they wear socks
I don't know every single day as long as
I sleep on a mat dude and the only sites
that I rock with my shoes you know I'm a
sneaker head bum bag I need the right
socks I'm talking bum bum buh
bombo's both they're made from super
soft natural cotton every pair comes
with arch support which is crazy
you must oh that's big now listen and
they're not a sonic either bro that's
huge when you put on a sock and you got
that seam and gets stuck between you and
the shoe causes your toes and discomfort
seamless toe on a cushioned footbed
that's comfy but not too thick you can
wear the following style in the gym at
the office out of town here's the thing
every bombas you purchase they donate a
pair to someone in need to make the
world a better place your feet are
comfortable you're making the world a
better place
sock at a time by Obama's at bombas
dot-com slash fighter today and get 20%
off your first purchase that's Bo MBA
Escom slash fighter for 20% off bombas
comm slash better turn offense that's an
event curtain offense chin take some
drugs I want some overall times it's so
freaking good oh good god I wish we had
more yeah charts in separate uber case
day happens so there was a video of Andy
Dick getting into an altercation with a
couple of guys and the story came out
that apparently there were two guys who
were working for uber eats one guy was a
driver and I guess the other guy was his
brother who was just kind of helping him
okay the deliveries okay Andy approached
the car they were kind of talking and
eventually at Andy and the brother were
outside of the car and he tried to take
the food from the uber eats person
without paying over so yeah it wasn't
his food from what I gather yeah he just
kind of wanted his image okay right he's
a terrible drunk yes okay yeah he
definitely seemed like he was drunk in
this video he tried to take the food the
guys try to take it back but it also
seemed like they were kind of messing
with him because they knew who he was
you're recording this entire altercation
on man when things started to get a
little more physical and he kind of
swiped at the brother and the Oberer
eats you a very brother I saw him he was
hitting him this is the end so players
aged bigger brother
yeah the older brother ended up grabbing
Andy and tossing him to the ground so
he's trying to grab the food and snot
his food
yeah he's hammered he's off incoherent
yeah he's also trying to kiss dudes
that's why you're knocked out that first
time but they're all laughing but now
and it gets crazy now listen these guys
man I'm put this on TMZ but also if
you're gonna be drunk and your
Gloucester people suck like leave Andy
alone young guys no watch this bub I
know but leave all alone I like Andy a
lot he's my love Andy in a lot of ways
but Andy no dude Andy Kayleigh was
leaving and then this guy something I
want to tell you something about this
person okay watch him watch him he's
trying to keep him away guys moving back
so that was a spit that looks like a
happen but he's gonna get in trouble for
this
can I can I just say something wash kiss
me spits on yes he spit on them yeah let
me let me taste them so so I like him
apart
I've known Andy for I've known Andy
since I did Newsradio so that's song
yeah I know people who work with Andy
yeah I know people everybody likes handy
and he's a great guy Andy is a terrible
drunk I've seen with my own eyes him
behave in a way that is simply
unacceptable it's out of control and
that is mild and so he's lucky he didn't
get like when he got knocked out like
that at that when he was standing there
I'm surprised that doesn't happen no all
the time my guess is he probably tried
to kiss that guy no like the guys say
I'm grabbed his dick probably something
like that which is again he's been in
trouble for that many times I love Andy
but Andy has a major problem with
alcohol and and he's got to get serious
help because he when he does drink it
gets it gets dangerous for him terrible
and and he gets he just gets after a
while as a person you're gonna defend
yourself and he's gonna put you in a
position where you're gonna have to do
something like that and it's not even
malicious he's not a very
good mean great guy but he's out of
control he's out of control yeah
obviously and the universe tends to or
punish you for they working - no no yeah
it'd be cow keep how I don't know how do
you I don't know go get how are you
trying to get on stage I don't know when
you have a production no I know there's
no way he's so talented and funny
he's so planned of course you want him
but well I can't have that that's an
issue that's such a so I just wish him
will have to watch yeah so lies I love
him he's a great person he's so [ __ ]
funny and talented he's just right now
he looks like he's in the middle of
something very tough yeah and you got it
you got to fix it because the world we
don't nobody cares at the end of the day
I care about him but I'm too busy
everybody's too busy the world just
keeps moving forward and you end up in
jail it's what happens I don't I don't
know what yeah I mean keeps going down
Aaron tells TMZ he doesn't spit on
anyone he claims the group offered him
some tacos when he reached to get them
they pulled the plate away he says the
next thing he knew he's being tackled
from behind you can see him spinning
yeah yeah so the two Oberer eats the
delivery guys are pressing charges right
now and Andy Dick says that he actually
wants to go and follow his own charges
against them look why is anyone pressing
charges why just give you separate ways
why is anybody precious charge here you
slammed a me down on his [ __ ] head
he's a drunk
what do you press charges again well he
has another uber eats case where he
grabbed a female worker um on her ass so
mr. Perret sipar dude he's fine you know
me I defend everyone oh it's yeah you
know I want everybody to be okay but
he's there's a pattern here there's a
pattern just this is this is the norm at
this point I'm sorry it's too bad man
yeah that doesn't end well
oh there are my father said to me and
whenever I was 14 15 we were late for
something he said we were gonna miss
this boat and he goes he made it he'd
look at me he goes I wanna come here for
a second said that I knew I was in deep
[ __ ] because you were gonna miss the
boat
I was just a [ __ ] idiot I [ __ ] up
with scheduling and he goes ideas I mean
I mean let me tell you something how it
goes I want you to hear me
there are no excuses in the real world
there are no excuses
I don't care there are no excuses I
don't care what happened you either got
it or you don't you can either do it or
you can't get it and the world goes next
I never forgot it he scared me with it
he scared me he goes I don't care in had
I didn't get into [ __ ] the college I
wanted to and I wanted to go to the
college because my girlfriend was I was
in love with a college Wesleyan and he
go my mother's like you know it's ok I
know it's hard my father goes it's not a
hard hold on hold on
if you want to be a Wesleyan student you
have to do what a Wesleyan student does
and you didn't do that you don't get to
be that and that's the way it is I love
that [ __ ]
bottom line [ __ ] heartbreakingly
heartbreaking but true get it together
God Poor Dad that does not matter I
[ __ ] wasn't working I had one sub I
wasn't working as an actor and I was
like 33 years I was I got [ __ ] I can't
get a job I don't know I can't get a job
it's just I hung in and he goes yeah
this is what you signed up for right
this was the choice she made right
Papa's right Papa's right yeah but dads
are there for so a confused deer ran
into a hair salon through the window and
scared the [ __ ] out of a couple people
well that's why deer should all be
killed
my favorite says black lay laying on the
couch you would be sis's goodness only
like grabs our iced tea or some [ __ ]
she's going still there
he's just walking up that salon that's
so great great oh holy [ __ ]
maybe zoom like that ladies reaction
that guy maybe I haven't seen let go
back and see him die I just watch the
old lady because she's so slow to move
that thing jumped over her this everyone
shot she's hiding behind her thing God
dog nothing [ __ ] in trolley I could
have been bad I could've hit her right
in the head herself oh that literally
killed that lady fat bucket in the back
of the head did you see how a horse
kicked that other horse to death did we
do that yeah we saw that girl that's
great Jesus not if you're that horse oh
no no oh okay sorry confuse little drunk
got into semi but look at their eyes
erode so how do I know that I get hit by
car I don't know it's incredible oh
that's how oh that's fantastic
I'm out of here see you later guys gotta
get the [ __ ] outta here just the street
twin I break the window and leave see
you later Oh psychically on this one
what us yet so I saw a couple things
going around about this do you know more
about this situation it went a video of
Snoop Dogg performing at Kansas went
viral because he had tripperz tripperz
and then he was throwing around fake
hundred-dollar bills and a cash machine
yeah I don't get why it's a story I
don't either I know the so Bill Self the
head coach is on my things on probation
because he violates some in the NCAA
which is the most crooked business in
the world makes tons of money you know
off the kids and doesn't pay anybody so
Snoop Dogg gets brought so if you bring
Snoop Dogg to your school you know it's
Snoop Dogg so doggy style [ __ ] and
hos gin and juice like this is does this
think so
he had like a
girl dancing on a like fake stripper
pole he's making it rain and everybody's
all up in arms the the University have
to apologize to people like we're so
sorry we did this it's like why this why
is this news who gives a - nobody does
except for a small group of [ __ ] who
are super woke and I've decided that
it's their the anti fun anti-sex police
so in general the frisbee Hitler loved
it
you have every student there loved it
course every recruit who's there loved
it of course
Bill Self loved it it's a people I never
get laid it's the shitty it's the shitty
people with we don't we're not part of
this so we don't we can't dance we don't
like it yeah can't get the girl in a
pole can't be the ground up oh [ __ ] off
keeps going down and then ugly chicks
like this this is yeah look at that
well it's more of an ideology it's not
about it's just some of them are just
they're just sour grapes
is there anything uh watch I'm watching
you play a video this one here yeah
probably all just how great would that
be if your culture you also dropped the
anyone singing so are you upset about
that hold on come on man also for this
is me and the audience
oh I don't get why this is a curtain I
don't get what it's a news story he's
still got it he's 60 with cornrows is he
60 he's getting up there's no way that
old because he's older how old do you
think the scene weighs 19 I was probably
five years younger me oh thank you for
yours I thought it was a tad that was in
a lot of these I thought a lot of weed
yeah during the damn thing every bit of
six four I would say six five did a
reading with him once now there's dr.
Dave it makes for [ __ ] my thighs are on
that same age we're 77 million dollars
he's all seven hundred and seventy
million what I think 77 yards
what else we got had some money I'd love
to have that kind of money ooh a man in
Florida was arrested for getting caught
trying to basically detach the brake
line from these electric scooters people
saw he's a he's a what is it a social
idea just wants to see people get hurt
there are people like this they they
they're artists of pain they just want
to watch somebody die but secretly I
mean anyone who gets on scooters you go
gasps break oh they don't work I'm just
gonna go the next one I didn't know
here's a sociopath look he looks like
one too
yeah oh you know he's doing he's
probably list some old dude stuck in his
ways doesn't like that these scooters
are around if I'm getting people injured
on he's hoping they're gonna they're
gonna just even he's awesome oh guy that
wears TV a--'s with [ __ ] shorts
Jackie Shore he's also an evil he's this
is Florida Florida yeah there you go
he's just evil though he's probably just
an evil man I love he's evil I just
think he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] that thought
by doing this he could get rid of
scooters in the area what a scumbag
so this footage was found on one of his
neighbor's ring alarm systems they
reported it to the police and they
actually found that a lot of scooters
within his area within the last two
months had their brake lines cut I
nothing do things by doing this and
you're the scooter he wants to hurt
somebody he wants somebody to get on
their bite and then that would be able
to stop and get killed
that's what he's doing is it Morris you
can go fast in those you can go like you
feel pretty fast so the Olson you don't
you don't have brakes mm-hmm and he's
trying to see somebody get hit by a car
killed he people like that get off on it
sits and reads about it sociopath yeah
sociopath a sadistic sociopath Thanks it
probably does much worse than that
that's why that's why you should put
that guy down yes I killed in the back
there no let's move on kill what are we
gonna do with it I'm in prison shoot him
shoot him I that's a bad person theme to
the great whites thank you
what do you need Chum in the water there
you go gonna drop you off here and
Guadalupe Island about about a day
offshore enjoy that and see if you can
swim back go swim around Catalina yeah
entertain the tourists
chum the waters yeah what else get to
amber Geiger the cop that walked into
the wrong apartment
and shot him so you know she got 10
years right yes
what happened this is both of them the
guy that was killed his brother and he
wanted to give her a hug after he shows
a [ __ ] man
yeah how did you do that it was very it
was he said I forgive you have you guys
looked at this case much this guy I mean
I've seen the case much how it man it's
[ __ ] shady because they say she goes
in and then she's like realize not him
and then still says like get your hand
on your pot like the way she talks it's
a shame and he jumps to killing him way
too fast she was terrified she got an a
she went in the wrong apartment
it makes sense is that it all looks the
same that that can happen I've done that
it's a terrible tragedy and she's you
know I I don't think she should I think
it was a horrible accident
I don't think she should go to jail for
murder I think it's terrible but watch
this brother watch this watch this
brother watch how luckily he does 18
year old Brant Jean forgiving amber
Geiger he lost his brother killer that's
how you make the world a better place
yeah well I'll tell you he's not doing
that I can speak for myself
J Saab you done a bit shank this lady in
the [ __ ] is never here say that right
now
but it doesn't ring but bring her
brother back he does it I understand
there's certainly it takes a certain
helps him and her his forgiveness is
[ __ ] powerful he must really believe
that she made a poor guy a mistake he
doesn't want her to go to jail either he
said he's his family part just want to
hear him say that
twist you know the twist of this right
the key witness in this case
Bert yes this guy that's strange he was
his neighbor the crosses to cross the
hall so he now he's been used on who's
saying that he heard things right yeah
and then that yeah and then he say
didn't hear her say say but yeah now we
don't know but III do think this woman
was destroyed you think it's a
coincidence that the neighbors murdered
the key witness but it was after she got
sentenced so it's probably white
supremists or something who knows yeah I
don't know who could have been
you know what the thing it's just a all
around it's that terrible her life it's
ten years and your Prime your father
someone lost a life the family screwed
nice the whole thing it's like she's a
cop in jail tragic her lease is a female
jail yeah I heard she could be eligible
for parole in like five years I think it
sort of figured her out early mmm-hmm
it's just tell us you got more thing
this crazy woman at an AOC Town Hall
move you her no no Hannah just see I'll
just wait where you can get it I'm crazy
woman we have that she might have been
trolling it dis it seems like you just
had to be trolling she just tried to
make Nettie Bravo sent this to me last
two questions come from Lurline grant
and Nicole Mac Zoe may you raise your
hands please
climate crisis we only have a few months
left I love that you support the Green
Deal but it's not get it you know
getting rid of fossil fuel it's not
gonna solve the problem fast and never
spring the swedish professor saying that
we can meet that people but that's not
fast enough so I think your next
campaign slogan has to be this we got to
start eating babies we don't have enough
time there's too much co2 all of you
you're you you know your pollutants too
much co2 we have to start now you are so
great I'm so happy that you really
support a nuclear deal but eat the
children say the planet eat the children
Russia we still have too many people too
much pollution so we have to get rid of
the babies that's a big problem just
stopping a baby's ass I realize we need
to eat the babies under the spaces
please
No thank you thank you she was very nice
to ALC okay so thank you get out the
crazy [ __ ] so I think I'm out of time
for people like this [ __ ] idiot
okay let's see you as she's trolling
okay hey all right okay that's like
doing with really drunk people after a
show my favorite it's just like all
right yeah that's some big crackhead
energy that's cracked that LS you see I
was just crazy she's just not good some
people are so out of their [ __ ] minds
well yes yeah I do agree with her though
yeah but you know this is gonna suck for
you guys cuz you travel a lot oh yeah
lax is gonna get rid of just on just act
the terminal right very lifts to
traverse Allah phrases helps us does it
yeah if you travel what this helps this
so can Jessica's so many you burn Mars
it's me but I always take Guran left I
don't I part why this helps me right
here get [ __ ] there yeah and I never
over homie yeah you're gonna have to
take a shot shuttle to a station or two
to a designated area which is like 15
minutes away enjoy that
no the sexy honey hat if we travel out
this helps its soon to its this month I
think that 29 fantastic because the line
to get into the parking garage
geez it's out of control it's out of
control it's there's too many cars so
this helps and an LA of course cuz in
their infinite wisdom this city was it
doesn't have the infrastructure for the
number of people we have it is the most
busy Airport I think in the country or a
second or and it's got to it is sewing
horrible planes that's why this [ __ ]
all the Democrats in Sacramento and I
have my problems with Republicans too
but Sacramento has been run by basically
hardcore Democrats are hardcore big
government people and all due respect
because I got a problem again with
Republican my way but they have not they
just seem to be [ __ ] we have the
second highest taxes in this [ __ ]
Union in the United States and how's it
going man how the [ __ ] is it going get
it together
you suck something a useless already
amazing council
they some you know this help eat alright
they lose then dude yet burbank's the
move dude wearing this so that Bank is
is I hear because it's a really nice
small little air you don't mean like
I've never waiting line there you'll
write to your gate the only problem is
everything small plans so it's like do
you think that jet though that West
chapter something or that you can jet
sweet but it's only a West Coast they
don't go long distance it's only like
see Arizona Arizona Vegas kind of sucks
if you're on there it's great yeah but
if you want if you like a long plate to
say go to Philadelphia or New York or
Pittsburgh you and you fly out of
Burbank you're taking a small plane yeah
or they don't fly there at all so it's
like you do you want to go Burbank and
not sit with the [ __ ] traffic of LAX
or do you want to go LAX deal with it be
complied first you know I'm saying yeah
she said her bank is far far from me but
not for you know as far as easy he'd
been a Long Beach Airport that's another
really going to to that lacks it all the
way to it is far super here's the thing
they'll be in so I usually fly at 6:00
a.m. so to Burbank it's 23 minutes to
LAX 26 minutes oh that's like pick your
poison though right I'll fly it so early
the vehm Reina yeah you fly too early no
I always fired I can't do it no I don't
do with any traffic no line do you sleep
enough oh yeah you do well I me on the
road to get stuff sometimes do you need
what eight hours a big man
I'd like it just you know my son wakes
up at five but if you if you are left to
your druthers you so you can sleep eight
hours that's what you're totally
refreshed mmm maybe I feel like you
don't sleep at all I see you posting I
don't think I'm like like super late and
then super early
okay I'm not that yeah you need some
sleep yeah but you're good you're pretty
routine with your day so yeah what else
yeah one more your boy young Hoku
remember that kicker and the korean
kicker that you liked a lot but then he
didn't do well when he first got into
the NFL hmm he got signed to the
practice squad and the Patriots serious
[ __ ] but there you have a kicker
something happened with that guy this
released Kelvin always since I'm
watching hard knocks how are the Raiders
doing hard nuts they're actually really
good just one last night in London yes
he's just three and two or four into ice
and AFC West is not great
I love curtain theatre with it Johnny
come lately huh right now
I loved ridden as it just seems like
such a good guy so he's in Hatchin
practice squad what does that mean I
don't know enough about us see you nan
the 53-man roster and they brought you
in because that the the kicker you sir
doesn't do well then you come in it
something's going on because they never
have practice watch kickers so huh
something's going on maybe they're
kickers sucking dick or something I'm
all righty but not doing well kicking
the ball Katya is that it that's it all
right dude all right buddy well that was
a hell of a [ __ ] podcast do you think
guys already coming in hot dude I feel
when you street fight you know what I
mean still got a little little sweat on
the brow That's Life bro sometimes you
got to deal with people like that yeah
you didn't come to my rescue I called
you I know my phone do you never know
what the [ __ ] thank God I didn't go out
there be ready because it would have
been sit sit you should have been a real
situation yeah I would have gone throw
him in a Darce choke oh my god then that
bum bites my arm I get a riced
for what I don't think biting would
would work on you in a real fight what
it Biden [ __ ] dad were thugs you're not
fighting and I start biting oh my god
I'm out I'm not off you're really
fighting me I'm running you start biting
I'm running don't you crush my teeth
chunk of flesh and you go calm out man
I'm gonna choke you sleep and I'm choked
me I'm playing a run you start buying
the worst thing I can do is open my
mouth to try to bite him lies and you're
gonna go you got I don't know that was
[ __ ] suck yeah I can buy - hey is the
chompers myself I bite the [ __ ] human
mouth is strong it's wrong much worse to
die by biting by human than gray white
or crocodile isn't it ironic why why is
it dull teeth how would you rather die
by the gun chomp
by biting if I said you have died by
biting of course nobody wants that but
you're gonna die so you have a choice
human great white saltwater crocodile oh
who do you choose
I imagine human for some reason hey yo
how long it takes for a human to kill
you with his mouth it's gonna forever no
well not gonna happen after you are in
the jugular
like True Blood still takes forever no
no if you have a goatee True Blood it's
now this is it's gonna take forever
great white you just done they sharpen
so what rock crocodile just drowns you
you're fine you just die quickly
I don't know how could human just goes
oh I got small mouth this guy it's gonna
be dull without alligators grab you
crush all your bones paid dry you
underwater channel like a [ __ ]
blenders yeah everything you just like
okay you drown yes I'd be horrible it's
fine my mighty and hang on human
scissors you in half and you just bleed
to death now that one of those are
painful it didn't happen
hey come bite Brian though he's at Brea
oh yeah October 24 through 26 I'm buying
them October 24 25th 26th come see me
come by Brian the kid Callan let's go
get your tickets now I'm gonna buy Ewing
some heat yeah October 27th I'm doing a
benefit mm-hmm and it's a very for a
very good cause at the Comedy Store does
it this October 27th same thing I'll let
you know
yep you know you know my charity I'm on
one date with all days that October 27th
is Sunday that's a song it's gonna be
tricky
every truck it tricky but I need you and
I'm gonna have some good people
absolutely people I'll be there all
right buddy thank you me and Brendan
we're gonna have some friends by now you
know who those friends will be it's
gonna be some hitters some real hit up
in the heart which myself I will have
Kevin Hart just rock obama's major
Michelle Obama she'll he's gonna be
there Oprah Oprah good sound he's gonna
I don't know about that but she will be
doctors abundant giving out massages
just sill doctor my field will be there
LeBron James long James will be there
running H a bass guitar and let's say HD
800 but I made it without HD a you'll be
giving out samples of his blood so he
because whatever he's got in his veins
is super blood the buck that ran through
the salon welcome it ran through this
salon we'll be there that's right all
right I'm in Philly next weekend Friday
Saturday if everyone Julia me I can't
wait
we come get your tickets t pack a.com
after that I'm at the ice house on the
24th of October job and friends kill and
cancel
I saw shops friends I have some funny
friends there and then in November
Dallas Salt Lake City get your tickets
then just announced I will be in
Atlantic City
some giant casino there Atlantic City
December 14th I'm doing something fun
after the show as well with the fans
there get your tickets now too fat cake
I'm pretty big there in that picture
looking all muscular and whatnot swelled
up dude swole up we got we got a thinner
web page those are old pictures yeah
look at you for god sakes yeah I was a
long time I don't look at me I was it
yes my friend John John did that how's
that ESPN suck in the man's [ __ ] look at
us now dude yeah that's true you ready
yes PN that was a new one in Connecticut
middle of nowhere I remember that uh
Bristol Bristol Connecticut we see New
London mmm well just tickets Ryan myself
see you next week Philly go see Brian
and buy them tea vodka calm this the
fine kid we're out